the so-called gig economy work that
offers flexibility but no benefits such
as sick pay or maternity leave the labor
position would have equal rights for all
workers guaranteed hours and overtime
pay but that's not the job description
everyone wants I rather spend my time to
work on my project to grow my business
and in the meantime I can log in and out
on uber and get some extra cash and yeah
works for me he's pretty awesome I don't
have my self for me a zero contract has
been absolutely perfect to love me while
having severe illness to have an
employer who can revolve around my needs
last year around 3 million people in the
UK worked in a gig economy which
includes couriers cleaners and delivery
drivers like Sergio he delivers food for
the online platform delivery it's his
main job which he needs to support his
wife and four children but he's not
happy with how he's treated I have my
set of hours weekly with delivery with
the company if I don't work those hours
for in hell broken motor bike or
anything on the week following what they
do they kind of punish and take some
hours away the Labour Party has promised
to boost the rights of workers like
Sergio and restore the balance of power
in the workplace all workers will have
equal trade union rights from day one
whether they're part-time full-time
temporary or permanent zero hours
contracts will be banned so that every
worker gets a guaranteed numbers of
hours each week the number of people
working in the gig economy has boomed in
recent years economists say Labour's
plans could be difficult to implement
the risk is that some of these companies
might struggle to pay for some of the
benefits or the protections that John
McDonald is advocating for I think the
next step is to kind of figure out okay
whose responsibility is it is it just
the responsibility of businesses alone
do workers have to pay a bit more in
their contributions does the state also
have to make it
while the debate continues for those gig
workers they simply have to keep moving
and get the job done Charlotte Lomas Sky
News